The House
Select Committee
investigating January six,
convening publicly one last time.
He lost the 2020 election and knew it
in the end.
He summoned the mob to Washington
and knowingly they were armed and angry.
Pointed them to the Capitol
and told them to fight like hell.
And laying out its case
that former President
Donald Trump was ultimately responsible
for the attack on the U.S. Capitol.
No man who would behave that way
at that moment in time
can ever serve
in any position
of authority in our nation again.
He is unfit right for any office.
The committee referring multiple crimes
to the Justice Department
that they say
the former president committed while
trying to stay in the White House.
We believe that the evidence described
by my colleagues today
and assembled throughout our hearings
warrants a criminal referral
of former President Donald J.
Trump,
including assisting
or aiding an insurrection, conspiracy
to defraud the United States,
obstruction of an official proceeding,
and conspiracy to make false statements.
It believes there is sufficient evidence
for two others
conspiracy to injure or impede an officer
and seditious conspiracy.
The panel also referenced
Attorney and Trump
ally John Eastman to DOJ, but saying DOJ
will have to determine
who else should face prosecution.
Our understanding
of the role of many individuals
may be incomplete even today
because they refuse
to answer our questions.
We trust that the Department of Justice
will be able to form
a far more complete picture.
Republican lawmakers
who snubbed committee subpoenas
referred to the House Ethics Committee
after 17
months of
investigating and roughly a thousand
witness interviews.
The committee determined that Trump
knew the fraud allegations
he was pushing were false,
but continued to amplify them anyway.
The committee has evidence
that ex-President Trump
planned to declare victory
and unlawfully to call for the vote
counting to stop,
and that he told numerous allies
about his intent
in the weeks before the election.
Up say a couple of months.
Even as some of Trump's closest
allies, like Hope
Hicks, worry the bogus
fraud claims were damaging his legacy.
Trump persisted
He said something along the lines of,
You know,
nobody will care about my legacy
if I lose
so that won't matter.
The only thing that matters is,
is winning.
Trump worked on a scheme
to transmit
false Electoral College
ballots and replace
Department of Justice leadership with one
that would do his bidding,
even pressuring his own vice president.
President Trump
spearheaded an unprecedented campaign
to coerce him to do it anyway,
ultimately culminating
in a dangerous threat to Mr.
Pence's life.
On January six,
the committee
also highlighting Trump's
$250 million fundraising haul
between the election
and January six
raised primarily off
claims of election fraud
that did not exist.
Questioning whether any of the money
was used to pay lawyers
who may have tried to obstruct
the congressional investigation
and evidence from one unnamed witness
who was urged to stay loyal to Trump.
The witness believed
this was an effort
to effect her testimony.
And we are concerned
that these efforts
may have been a strategy
to prevent the committee
from finding the truth
DOJ may be
interested in
evidence the committee has to provide
if they do believe
there was some kind of obstruction.
But I think what we are already hearing
from witnesses,
including that lawyer from John Eastman,
is that
these referrals from the committee
are not legally binding.
They don't hold any more weight
than a referral from an American citizen.
The attorney from Eastman
also said that the committee
missed an opportunity
to make real legislative changes
by pursuing a pretend criminal case Jake.
All right.
Sara Murray on Capitol Hill for us.
Thank you so much.
Let's bring in January 6th
committee member,
Democratic Congresswoman
Elaine Luria of Virginia.
First, let me just get your response
to the attorney for Mr.
Eastman saying that
these referrals carry
no more weight
than any other referral
from any other American citizen
and basically attacking the committee.
Well,
I think this has been a standard practice
over the course of our investigation.
And that people attempt
to attack the committee,
discredit the committee,
rather than focus on.
The real issue here
is that we have a former president,
United States, who essentially attempted
to stay in office
after he lost an election.
There was also a comment
that Mike Pence made.
He attacked the partizan nature
of the committee, blah, blah, blah.
But the other thing that I thought was
interesting is this is how he spins it.
He said today,
look, as I wrote in my book,
I think the
president's actions and words
on January six were reckless.
But I don't know that
it's criminal
to take bad advice from lawyers.
What do you what do you make of that?
Well,
I'm actually kind of tired of Mike Pence
trying to have it both ways. He really
takes the limelight
and likes
to be portrayed as a hero who
because he did
his job and followed the law,
but at the same time
then goes back and tries to attack
a committee that is bipartisan.
Really, it's
been one of those bipartisan committees
in the House.
And the way
we've worked together
and presented the evidence
and the facts are the facts
and he has tried to discredit it
in the public sphere.
Many have tried to undermine the
nature of the composition
of the committee through the courts.
And the courts
have clearly rejected that.
The truth is, is
we did our job
as a congressional committee.
As for oversight
and legislation, we've laid out
the facts.
We've painted a very clear picture
for the American people of what led up to
and happened on that day.
It's spelled out in our report
the executive summary is out today.
Later this week,
the full comprehensive report
will be out, along
with all of the testimony
in the executive summary.
Look at the witnesses we have in there.
You know, nine
9% of them are Republicans
who served in the Trump administration.
And many of them were appointed
by Trump himself and performed by
his Republican Senate.
And those are the people
who had the courage to come forward
and speak and talk about the facts
So, you know, people who continue
to evade the questions of the committee
and try to undermine the committee
as a committee within Congress,
you know, they you know, Mr.
Eastman's lawyer said, you know,
it wasn't worth any more than,
you know,
potentially any citizen saying it.
You know, they're
you know, it's kind of it's hot air.
It's deflection.
I think and,
you know,
we get back to the point is
all of this should be focused on
the facts.
And we laid that out today
and our referrals.
It's true
that they don't carry the weight of law
and it's also true,
and I've said this early on,
I mean, the attorney general,
you know, Mr.
Garland, you don't have to wait for us.
And they haven't
they've been running
with this investigation.
And, you know,
since we're not coordinating our efforts,
their efforts,
you know, I've looked at this
like a relay with a passing off a baton.
The runner receiving
the baton is already running, you know,
and they've got to keep going with it.
So I think we've
you know,
our committee is coming to an end
because the end of this Congress,
we've issued a report
and we've passed this off
to the Department of Justice
with the full information we've gathered.
And we recommend that they look
at criminal activity of the people
starting at the top.
Trump, former President Trump.
So I know that the committee was
the select committee was only
formed for this one Congress,
but I also know that,
you know, midterm
elections generally
swing the way this one swung.
And, you know, Kevin McCarthy or whoever
the Republican speaker becomes
was going to kill the committee
even if it had been put in there
for for more than one term.
And I'm wondering
if you felt like you had enough time
and resources to investigate
everything you wanted to
when it came to the insurrection?
I think that we did
a comprehensive investigation
talking to a thousand
that this is roughly
hundreds of thousands of documents,
including a huge tranche of information
from the Secret Service.
I mean, this is not the end of this
we look at.
This is really the beginning in a sense.
You know,
as we said in the hearing today
for the Department of Justice
to take the information
that we've gathered
along with what they've gathered.
And the end of this is holding
people accountable
and making sure like this,
something like this doesn't happen again.
So
there's more to
be done than
we had time and ultimately resources for.
Do you think the January.
Do you think
the Justice Department
would have been as aggressive
as they've been?
And I know there are a lot of people
who think they haven't
been aggressive enough,
but I mean, they did get guilty
pleas for the Oath
Keepers on seditious conspiracy.
There have been other charges.
And who knows what's going to come.
Do you think that they would have done
as much as they did
if it hadn't been for the January six
committee kind of blazing a trail?
And on that subject,
why shouldn't the Senate form now?
The Democrats have 51 votes
and they can form committees
and have subpoena power, etc.
Why shouldn't the Senate
take up the stance now?
They were attacked, too?
Well,
as far as the Department of Justice,
I think
it's a lot of speculation
in some regards.
I mean, we know the Department of Justice
has been investigating.
I would look it's
looked at as concentric circles.
You know, it started on the outside.
They started with the people who they had
direct evidence of trespassing,
you know,
vandalism, you know,
attacking police officers.
And they were
the 900
people have been charged
And we kind of started the center
and worked our way out.
So this is,
I think, the point
when those two concentric
investigations of converge,
we're passing it off
to the Department of Justice.
And I would like to see them
go all the way to the top
and hold those people
in the highest levels
of trust of the American people.
As the former president
and others who have failed to come
speak to the committee under subpoena
to hold those people accountable
where applicable.
And you know,
the other thing about the Senate
is I certainly think, you know,
the Senate
having a Democratic majority
with 51 votes has the capability to take
especially the recommendations,
the legislative recommendations
that we've laid out
and move forward those inapplicable
know committees of jurisdiction
to make sure that we can
actually act on them.
I was always a concern of mine
is, you know,
we can lay out
what our recommendations
are legislatively
to process wise within different agencies
and departments in the government
to prevent
something like this in the future,
but not
holding the majority in the House
past these midterms.
We know
Kevin McCarthy, Jim Jordan,
they want to come in
the very people who didn't
comply with subpoenas for the House,
want to be the speaker of the House,
and they want to be the chair
of the Judiciary Committee in the House.
And they want to enforce subpoenas,
but they wouldn't even answer themselves.
And that how ironic is that?